أعتقد أن المحكمة كانت خاضعة ل
ضغط قوي جدا
وأن هذه الضغوط التي جلبتها
على نحو فعال
إلى الصياغة النهائية
لكن أعتقد أنه جاك شيراك لديه
فعل الكثير حتى تتمكن المحكمة من ذلك
التدخل كان هناك في جميع أنحاء
إجراء الكثير من الضغط و
في الواقع أنه في نهاية هذا مزدوج
النسبة التي ليست هي نفسها بالضبط
[موسيقى]
طبعا
بينما هو
لم تحسب في النهاية أو تلك
يمكن تخيلها بما فيه الكفاية
بسهولة في الترس الأول
التي ذكرتها
لأن القتل جريمة
مثل الرئيس الحريري
اخيرا واحد من رئيس الوزراء الى ريرى
زبون والبعض مطلوب
معهم
كانت هناك ضغوط بلا شك
أن الأسماء لا تظهر
أعتقد أن هذا هو السبب وهذا جيد
أيضا السبب
العلاقات مع سوريا كذلك
معقد
أعتقد أن النظام الغذائي الأول أولاً
فكر في النظام الغذائي نفسه
[موسيقى]